good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you're joining us
from welcome to simply learn we were
honored to have you join us today to
supporting innovation with agile with
your host shri krishna joshi o muhammad
seen that right shri krishna Josie my
name is Richard and after the century
will be mostly in the background helping
Krishna so that everything goes smooth
and then at the end we'll come back up
for the 15-minute question and answer
agile in today's world and project
management this is one of the biggest
buzz words out there agile both are
having a successful business and for a
successful career if you do not know
Krishna Krishna is director software
engineer at pegasystems worldwide india
pvt ltd and has over a decade experience
working with companies and agile
environment including the help building
a new teams and new companies going from
0 to 100 million in less than two years
if you've ever worked with the startup
company that's impressive startup
companies have about eighty percent fail
rate and very few make it 200 million
very impressive he's always reaching to
exceed levels of excellence and quality
over the years has certified and
everything agile and scrum my has the
list was going to get down it they've
taken about five minutes and you know
great person to ask questions if you
have training questions for your company
or as an individual for your own career
path you know he's an accomplished
expert in the field with hands-on and
this is a great place to ask those
questions for those who aren't familiar
with the webinar I want to introduce you
to your dashboard we have everybody on
muchs we hadn't have all the background
new sounds and everything going so go
ahead and use that question model to ask
your questions if it's minimized you can
click on the red arrow to maximize it
again if you go and just say hi go ahead
and say hi to Krishna let them know
you're excited to be here this also
gives us a chance to check our sound
system make sure it's working and a high
joshi mark great to have you excellent
glad to have you guys here say to have
everybody here hello Krishna from Neelam
that they can you limp so yeah make this
is your best friend as you're going
through the thing you come up with
questions you can post them here
generally we save them for the end at
the last 15 minutes sometimes I do
interrupt if it's appropriate or if it's
if I'm able to and sometimes the answers
the questions during the session if you
hear something awesome brilliant
interesting insightful and you want to
share it in your social channel whatever
your social channels are facebook
linkedin tweet you can use the hashtag
SL webinars that way people can find it
and you'll make them wish they were here
you didn't come here to listen to me i'm
proud to introduce krishna who will be
your host for supporting innovation with
agile go ahead sit back relax have a cup
of coffee tea or if it's evening where
yeah maybe a glass of wine kick back and
enjoy it's an honor from you hand this
over hello Krishna how are you today I'm
doing great return thank you very much
for addie production excellent I'm gonna
go ahead and mute myself and let you
take it over yeah you just mentioned
wine and you know I have a mood changing
so I hope I can keep up right but thank
you for the introduction thank you very
much and hello everybody um like Richard
mentioned my name is Krishna and I'm a
passionate agile coach and I'm till to
welcome you all on this Learning Channel
over the you know next few next 40
minutes or so we will go over you know
how agile is fueling innovation and you
know these tend to be the most common
passwords this is so we can go over
those and you know given that richard
has already given my introduction I'll
just skip this part um and jump right
into the agenda so I'm sure most of you
here are most of you here must have
heard about both of these buzzwords that
have been doing the rounds for you for
close to a decade now at least a decade
when you know I think there's been a lot
of emphasis on innovation so over the
next 45 minutes
go with these four areas in this webinar
you know a traditional ad versus the
agile project management now we'll go
over innovation and you know how the how
the values for innovating and the
ideology has already been embedded about
your 16 years ago when you know the
agile manifesto came into being it back
in 2001 we also talked about you know
how we embrace and manage change in the
requirements as a result of market
dynamics or you know calm your
competition what have you and we're also
you know out towards the end look at you
know how continuous improvement / kaisan
is built into agile right so without
further ado let's jump straight in and
you know just so that we're all on the
same page and for some of you who are
you know starting new with agile um and
are you know getting to hear these
buzzwords quite a bit let's let them sit
everybody and let's have a common
understanding of you know what these two
buzz words actually mean so innovation
if you look up on google or the
dictionary is it comes from the latin
word it's called um you know where and
that means to renew or to change right
and agility if you will are agile is the
ability to embrace change quickly and
easily right so you know if you can
embrace change easily if you can
basically react fast to the changing
requirements of market dynamics and come
up with something that delivers value
that is perceived as innovation and and
as you can see on the screen arm you
know innovation is obviously as a state
of mind are you you know where whenever
you want to introduce a change then you
want to do it innovatively so you delve
a maximum value and
the bottom left with what you see is
plan do check hat so agile as you know
is a you know iterative and incremental
method for software development um and
as the picture shows this Deming cycles
demonstrates how the ability to change
is built in to the agile methods that we
steady gorham you know explore a little
more today right Embry now now what we
wanna know is the answer the question as
to why you know we should be we should
all be interested in trying to
understand this concept um and I have a
few personas here you know so that you
can relate to your one or more of these
and depending on what your background is
and who you are you know agile and
innovation you could be this little guy
here who was a manager who's trying to
basically you know improve quality
increase the employee morale or
basically improve a group of
productivity you could you know you
could be an entrepreneur um like you
know the steep drops negative that's
you're not here entrepreneur who's
focusing on a faster time to market
right and that's all these entrepreneur
/ startup companies one today used to
basically be able to hit the market
faster acquired that you know get it get
into doing somewhat of market
acquisition for whatever feel you are in
and then you know cash cash in and start
to continuously deliver value you could
be an innovation team or a part of an
innovation team who's trying to
understand you know what are the best
tools and techniques or what are the
best methods to basically drive
innovation by adopting agile
methodologies right so there's something
for for everybody you know in the
audience now you know you may fit into
one or more of these you know user
personas as I said so we'll try and
explore that a little bit
um so now the big question you're
continuing the big question and you're
trying to answer this question is why
should somebody you know follow and add
embrace an agile method which you know
in turn fuels innovation there are case
studies and this is not me saying all of
this information is freely available on
the internet if you want to you know go
ahead and look up there are there
there's close to about you know a
thousand organizations that have been
surveyed and these surveys to happen you
know almost every year to try and figure
out the benefits that agile
organizations are deriving by
organizations are having by embracing
agile methodologies they tend to be far
more innovative as a result of which you
know they in terms of processes in terms
of products what have you and hence they
engage better with their customers there
these are the organizations that have
been surveyed whose quality levels have
improved by over fifty percent their
productivity employee productivity has
gone up anywhere between twenty to fifty
percent they have far more happier and
motivated employees and their time to
market is now 30 to 75 percent faster
right now we have a range here which
indicates that not all organizations get
the same kind of benefit you know it's
kind of very and you can look up
multiple histories you know on skeletal
framework com /k studies as well if you
want to see you know how organizations
have you know developed a culture of
innovation by you know embracing and
adopting the agile methodologies i'd
also like to you know at you know
introduce to you one of these case
studies that i came across and this is
published by the folks you know for a
business review and according to forbes
in 2006 i'll name the company because
this is you know one of these most
popular company are one of the most
popular companies in the world and this
is a company of just getting the great
places to work ranking number one you
know for the past DK um and some of you
may have already guessed it that this is
salesforce.com and and because they they
were you know honest they came out and
published their results we already know
this you guys can look it up on Google
as well you will find it back in 2006
Salesforce leadership came to realize
that their innovation was coming to a
halt and with just one product release
in 2006 says was for very disappointed
obviously because you know in the
previous five years they were delivering
an average of at least four major
releases eat here right so due to this
the software company decided that you
know they wanted to change the
management style to focus and become far
more customer driven right and be much
more collaborative with customers and in
basically being far more outcome
oriented and having an iterative
management practice and that is what we
know today as you know agile so which is
what is doing wonders for salesforce com
and this is and you know this is not
just qualitative winders and I'll else
you know I'll also share a few numbers
that are published and available on the
net if that's enough motivation for all
of us to understand and embrace agile um
my cone who's also a very you know very
noteworthy author in the world of agile
published that in the year in the first
year of Salesforce making the switch
from traditional to you know agile
methods salesforce.com released
ninety-four percent more features right
that's that speaking of the productivity
that we see up here and you're speaking
of individual productivity there yes
salesforce com also was able to
measure productivity of p.m. /
individuals but on average every
individual is productivity grew by
thirty eight percent because agile was
giving them the windows of opportunity
to stop and innovate at regular time
intervals right so that's huge right so
ninety-four percent more features
delivered thirty-eight percent more
features / developer and overall when
they surveyed their customers they were
able to figure out that they were
delivering 500 you know five hundred
percent more value to the customers and
speaking of employee engagement that ear
the employee satisfaction survey are the
GP TW survey that I spoke about which is
a great place to work survey ninety-two
percent of employees said that they
would very strongly recommend you know
if are basically refer a friend or a
colleague to work for this company and
then they would very strongly do so
because of the agile approach that was
helping create self-organizing and you
know self-empowered things that that you
know Salesforce was able to build over
time right I thought that's I thought I
thought this case study is so important
because we all know about this giant and
I think that's a fantastic story to draw
inspiration from and try and understand
dig a little deeper into how sales first
glad to do it right so that said you
know moving on I wanted to also you know
introduce to you or basically give us a
refresher or bring to your notice the
specific areas in the agile manifesto
and that you're basically proves that
innovation are the ability to embrace
change was inherently built into the
agile manifesto when it was created so
the ideology are the values are very
strong proponents of supporters of agile
/ innovation right so most of you may
already be familiar with these uh you
know agile values you know individual
and interactions over processes and
tools working software over
comprehensive documentation customer
collaboration over contract negotiation
and responding to change right which is
your ability to embrace change is what
makes you innovative over following a
plan well these are the actual values
you know you will all agree that there's
about 12 principles are 12 agile
principles two of those agile principles
very strongly you know do mention they
need to embrace changing requirements
depending on the market conditions
depending on you know the that the
providers are you know but circumstances
skill sets what have you you know the
principle number two says welcome
changing requirements be agile right
embrace change and find out innovative
ways to embrace those changing
requirements even if it's late in
development right agile processes
harness change for customers competitive
advantage you know so it's all about
embracing the changes to deliver value
which is in the best interest of the
customer at the same time there's
principle number 12 it speaks about you
know the the need for us to inspect and
adapt at regular intervals right and
attack basically again is to change
depending on you know how the computers
are making it move you know what will
give us the the market differentiators
you and you know how how the market is
changing how technology is changing and
things like that if we if we pick up you
know if we sign up for software projects
and don't visit or basically you know
don't have these intervals to frequently
inspect and adapt we will only be
bearing the customer a year later by
when both the market conditions the
technology and the customer environment
would have changed not her hence you
know we will that that way miss
out on the opportunity to e you know
more agile more collaborative and
deliver to the customer what they really
want right now not that's the agile
manifesto it's also through a little bit
more light on why the traditional you
know soft traditional software
development methodology did not have
this room to basically innovate or be be
more agile so you know requirement
management as we all understand in the
conventional methodology used to be two
to have a requirement you're gathering
phase in the very beginning and we would
only say that we complete you we would
only say that this phase is complete
after we've fully understood what it is
that the customer warrants or what it is
that we think that the customer wants
which means that we do a you know very
exhaustive process of gathering
requirements from the customer you know
we try and define everything up front
and we start you know that becomes our
starting point and then we go away and
then build a software in a cave if you
will right and the customer never gets
to see it till we're done now that II
you know is no longer acceptable right I
mean you know this may be acceptable in
the real estate industry right where you
know requirements don't change so very
often we don't go back to the Builder
and say you know we you've basically
here shown as a plan in which here's a
kitchen and here's a bedroom can you
swap it Midway you don't do that or or
we don't do that that often right we
don't do that you know conventional if
you're booking a flat or what have you
you don't do that at all if you speak
off you know a slightly different
example the average age of an aircraft
for domestic Airways in the United
States is about 70 years right that
means that the physical body or projects
like those which require you know
physical labor or machines they don't
change so often you speak of the
knowledge workforce or software think of
how often the same aircraft's technology
are you know a technology to interact
between the cockpit and the ground staff
and the cockpit and the airport staff
how frequently does that change and send
out alerts on the various you know
resilient apps that we have which give
us flight related information so that
all of that that's changed though right
so so conventional projects are our
conventional methodology is still good
when the requirements are rock solid and
they do not change right as opposed to
that in agile you know only high level
product backlog is you know it's
basically frozen upon it up front and
then the batter up is progressively
elaborated or progressively constructed
as we you know make progress right and
the planning approach you know I think
you know it stems from the fact that it
is if it's waterfall then there's heavy
emphasis on heavy efferent planning as
opposed to that agile methodologies have
rolling wave planning which means that
you basically you know the plan do check
act you know do it take a stock of the
situation and then plan for the next I
duration so you just plan for one
iteration at a time and I tration give
or take is anywhere between one to four
weeks at the max the most common eight
iteration length is about two weeks in
agile software development you do not
make all the decisions in the beginning
of the release right because you know
either the market conditions could
change your competitors scenario could
change or your ablative value it could
change you know one of these so you
don't make all of those decisions you
try and focus on the highest priority
items first and deliver those and then
after it will every two weeks you
inspect and adapt and then take up the
next set of requirements right so
similarly scope is something that you
don't tightly control in agile
as opposed to waterfall where you're you
know where your oh the whole control
mechanism is around scope you you know
the moment the customer says I have a
change requirement or I changed my mind
if we basically go back them with a you
know change request and and put them
through the change control board which
is very torturous so which is not in the
best interest of the customer anyways so
we work in favor of the customer and say
that in the two weeks window when the
Sprint is you know in flight we do not
change the scope but we can change that
at the end at every sprint boundary and
project management approach is you know
is predominantly focused on on cost and
schedules whereas you know the project
management approach in agile is to be
flexible and and we embrace change in
requirements to satisfy the business
neck right now that we've spoken about
that I also wanted to bring you know
introduce to you the the agile framework
or the workflow if you will and also you
know firstly walk you through the
process real quick and also show you
opportunities where we can embrace
change / where we can innovate right so
like every you know a project this
project also starts with the product
owner getting us a prioritized or a
ranked list of backlog items that are
basically taken up to plan for the
upcoming sprint we only would take up
you know if you can see the color
combinations you know the color patterns
only the ones that are in orange I
picked up which means that the top
priority items go in the first sprint
and so on and so forth so we we work in
order of priority the team basically
picks up whatever they think they can
consume in deliver in two weeks and you
have a plan for it break it down into
tasks you know estimated and then
whatever can be delivered at the end of
two weeks a two-week I trations the team
basically commits to it and then every
single day the team basically meets
for something called the daily scrum or
the stand up meeting right and all
through these two weeks the team is
doing continuous the team is trying to
be you know living up to the big key
agile tenants which is to be transparent
inspection transparency inspection and
adaptation so the team tries to live up
to these key tenants of a jet
transparency by trying to showcase
progress through burn down charts Kanban
boards if you will inspection is by you
know doing peer reviews it could be by
doing QA reviews it could be by doing
sprint reviews I could be mixed print
reviews as wet right and an adaptation
is obviously opportunities to change the
way we do work or change the scope of
work itself and those opportunities are
also available daily you know hourly or
you know for that matter definitely
available during the Sprint
retrospective um where we also would be
reviewing you know how much we we got
done and why we didn't get done as much
as we thought we would if you if we will
now having said that let's look at where
are now the opportunity is to basically
introduced change now the first
opportunity is right here before this
before we start spring if the product
owner figures that's something that he
that has been discovered very recently
needs to be you know shifted up in
priority put it up let's assume that
user story three in the first print was
only you know half then or there were a
few bugs found that need to be fixed
however you know it turns out we are
what we have a funding meeting coming up
in like the next two weeks and we
absolutely must take up story number six
and showcase that to the angel investor
so 12 along with six will probably make
up the perfect set of features or use
cases to showcase to this investor so in
which case three
which is kinda half then or for that
matter you're not fully done done will
basically take the back seat it
basically goes down in priority it sits
in the back lot and six gets a prize I
item number six gets you pulled up so in
the next print we will possibly start
working with added number six and five
or maybe you just focus on getting six
done first because 12 and six now will
basically make the perfect recipe for us
to showcase excuses so product backlog
shuffling prepare prioritizing ranking
you which is the primary our deliverable
from the product or this is one
opportunity for us to introduce that
change and be innovative right be
innovative in the best interest of the
business if we don't get the venture
capitalists funding will probably no
longer have the money to sustain and
stay in business we also have the
opportunity in the sprint planning
meeting if somebody figures that taking
up a specific story at this stage you
know we'll we'll have a lot of
vulnerability or has a dependency on a
different theme delivering something
else we can you know negotiate with the
product owner to see if something can be
pushed to a later stage or if something
else can be advanced in in lieu of that
so that's another opportunity to be you
know smart and a be innovative number
three is what you see here every single
day we get to know as to what will stand
yesterday what's the plan for the next
24 hours and you know if there's any
impediments coming in the way of
delivering value and once we know the
impediments that are blocking the top
stories you know let's say there's three
individuals or lesser there's ten
individuals the first couple of
individuals are working on the top
priority story and they are stuck they
are stuck because either they don't have
the skill or they don't have the you
know bit they underestimated specific
story what have you they are at risk of
delivering that story in time so that
you know either different
you can consume it or either because
they have we have to show that to the
angel investor in which case guys who
working on other lower priority stories
it could be you know person number five
or six or seven in the team they will
know in the stand up and they will
switch gears or they should discuss and
switch gears and say hey I'm working on
a low priority story you were going to
higher priority story I think I have the
background in the experience to be able
to help will you you know you is there
an opportunity that I can join you guys
and then they figure out whatever works
best to ensure that the highest priority
story gets delivered well in time so
depending on what the impediments are
and what the highest priorities or
commitments are for that sprint number
four is obviously sprint review meeting
where the team basically here will
showcase the work that they did over the
show and tell the work that they did in
the last two weeks right depending on
the feedback that they get either from
you know the quality architect or it
could be the product owner depending on
the feedback that they get they would
obviously be able to change or basically
adapt in how they take a specific
functional or a technical approach in
the upcoming sprint on similar stories
now that's a sprint review and needless
to say there are some teams who don't
wait till the end of the sprint to show
stories to their product owner there are
teams who do either Mitch print reviews
or if there are teams that are even more
fortunate that have a local product
owner they show and tell you know the
stories that are complete every couple
of days or if it's any more product
owner then they would do a screen share
and show that and for which this is
where we need a extremely supportive and
engaging and a committed product owner
for the team sprint retrospective while
the Sprint review will tell us give us a
quantitative reflection
and also at you know feedback from
product owners on how we should change
the functionality or technology or
basically to change our approach the
Sprint retrospective is a process or a
qualitative feedback which tells us what
should change in the process right and
you know so that's how where we discuss
what's going well what isn't going well
what's a what's a propeller what's a
derailer and you know what are some you
know things that we should continue to
do so those are again so these five are
clearly opportunities for us to you know
stop and reflect a pause and reflect on
you know what we could do differently to
achieve and deliver greater value right
that's it every time we say that we have
to you know manage embrace change and
you know basically embrace change to
ensure that we both in the best interest
of the customer this is a clear
trade-off and so should it as you can
see from the picture if one of these
pebbles is if this is the amount of
value that we're expected deliver if you
basically take off one of these you know
there's an imbalance right so this
either they'll either be a perception
that we've been deliver enough value you
know of are you know so to basically
mitigate to that and to continue to
create that balance we can only take up
you know something else if a product
owner asks us to change this specific
requirement we could replace it you know
once the Sprint is in fact we could only
replace it if we have something else
that's tantamount which is you know the
estimate for you know at the other story
is equal to the story that it's being
replaced with otherwise it obviously
creates an imbalance on either the
customers and order discipline set right
so you know whenever somebody says at
the same time you can't have something
lighter you could possibly have two
stories which are let's say half the
size of this one to replace this one bit
at the same time you
cannot have something heavier than this
pebble or this tone that you're
replacing if it means that you're trying
to you know take on much more and that's
not sustainable pace right how do you
embrace change so another illustration
uh you know shown here basically shows
us how we if this whole thing is the
product backlog how do we embrace change
if this a story let's say 1 2 3 that the
fourth one in the sequence ranked number
four if that is to be replaced then it
needs to be replaced with something else
of equal size and you know of pretty
much the equal size so the team doesn't
have to work overtime or is
underutilized and they even the customer
or the voice of the customer the product
owner does not perceive that the team is
delivering you know much less value than
what they capable of right so that's one
thing we could do that at the same time
if there are stories that need to be
really prioritized you to embrace change
to enjoy you know market conditions
could have changed the story you could
have been could have gained momentum or
the customer or the your birth
management of the UM business advisory
council may want to see this story ahead
of this one so we might just switch
those are priorities to give you an
example if we're building an e-commerce
site there's obviously functionalities
like login that we need to create this
obviously functionalities like you know
payment gateway um and a few your
product lines that need to be added
right there could be instances when
somebody's trying to introduce a
discount coupon code and say hey you
know what if you want to basically this
may be a good feature to have but that
cannot take priority over things like
having a shopping cart or having a login
screen or having a user profile right at
the same time if there's a way to
introduce a search functionality ahead
of your anything else then we might pre
sequence it and so on and so forth so
sequencing you know can happen depending
on while the product owner is the one
who's spending is fifty percent of his
time with the team in trying to clarify
requirements and then you accept stories
and yeah and so on and so forth the
other fifty percent of the time the
parrot owner is meeting with either
industry principles customer advisory
boards or customers themselves and doing
multiple interviews to understand you
know what it is that they're looking for
in terms of requirements in the you know
next two or three or four Sprint's from
that that point now what's highest
priority for them in and basically
trying to play those scenarios in mind
trying to comprehend those doing those
you know head taking help from the user
experience guys in trying to do
wireframes arrive at wireframes to
ensure and basically validate that the
end is that the customers expectations
and our understanding of those
expectations are the same and once we
understand those better and you'll be if
we had originally had a list and during
a successive customer compilation if
that the rank of that list has to change
the product owner would very well do
that to ensure that we are innovative in
trying to capture and deliver the item
of the highest value first right ahead
of our competition or basically you know
in the best interest of our customer
similarly they could also be items which
do not which we are which are kind of
you know wishful items so this these
could be you know discount functionality
or applying discount coupon so what had
these were originally in scope and
that's we only had a single line item to
say introduced the discount
functionality or features in the
e-commerce portal we had we had not
gotten into details to basically you
know get get granular levels to figure
out what should be the impact of
applying a discount code how should the
validation algorithm work how should the
totals change should we show that in the
totals through
should we also update the customer
profile to show the total number of
discounts that is we basically benefited
from you know since the time you know we
introduced this discount functionality
and so on so forth so we haven't
discussed those details or we haven't
and those out so at some stage if we
have the time then we would you
basically you refine these items these
big items break them down smaller
meaningful chunks and add more detail
they could also be items which no longer
make sense for you to work on right so
we have other better things to do so we
just delete these items as well so this
is just an illustration of how we
embrace change and manage the changing
requirements depending on a both out
whether via radio not and B how the
market conditions are changing market
dynamics competitor dynamics are
changing or technology is changing so we
could basically be agile by changing our
priorities to be in accordance with the
business and the business interest
that's it you know if we are constantly
focused on you're trying to get done
with everything that's shown up in the
backlog so we always have something
that's on top of the list and if you're
already if you're always focused on if
we laser focused on working on the
highest priority item all the time then
how do we find the time to do product
innovation right and so you know
obviously while there are opportunities
built in to the scrum and agile
framework there are organizations who
want to do product innovation and they
follow one of these so the scale agile
framework recommend something called VIP
sprint which is after every for sprint
there's an innovation and a planning
sprint for the upcoming sprint so that
could be you know a window set out and
some time window reserved exclusively to
come up with innovative innovative ideas
and such and plan for the upcoming
there's also organizations that are
doing hackathons that we see from time
to time amazon does a lot of this sales
first as this and so on and so forth to
try and encourage individuals within the
organization's to come up with really
really cool ideas that can be
prioritized obviously it's a win-win the
company benefits from these cool ideas
and also the developers get the sense
that they did they were able to
contribute to a piece of the product
that gives them the satisfaction there's
also innovation days or some
organizations call it shippee days and
these are days when you know we given
about 24 hours of window you just like
hackathons and we are expected to not
just present the idea but we're also
expected to basically show a working
prototype that can work and can be
scaled up you know if need be we just
published a day pick a day in the month
and say here's an innovation dates and
here's the time window some hog medicine
say that you just have a few hours some
say you have 24 hours but that they will
only we won't work up we won't talk
about mainstream work now but we will
you try and think outside the box and
then you come up with innovative ideas
and and like I said at a minimum the
best opportunity for us to you know
invest in these innovation the
innovation days hackathons shippy days
or what have you is done at the end of a
release or before just before a new
release begins right and that is when
you'll be not working really really
crazy trying to worry about either you
know the upcoming Sprint's deliverable
or the hardening index or you know or
what have you or anything else
unpredictable so the end of the sprint
you know images are given like a full
day to basically sit and think through
what it is that they would like to you
know deliver within a day and then they
do that so in summary
a there are obviously you know
opportunity we understood what
innovation is and what as L is you know
you could be one of these personas who's
trying to you you understand how
innovation will benefit you and we also
saw a few statistics industry-wide
statistics on how agility is fueling
innovation and how organizations are
able to get these tangible benefits we
saw we heard about the Salesforce case
study we also went over the agile
manifesto and the agile scrum framework
to figure out how and where there are
windows of opportunities that are built
into the framework that give us the
opportunity to to innovate em and we
also said how do we master the art of
embracing the changing requirements um
and in the you know in either the
product backlog prioritization are you
know are trading off requirements or for
that matter how do we how else do we
find the time to innovate when we
constantly focused on the top priority
items and there's always more than one
how do we constantly for how do we take
the time out to innovate a lot of
organizations are you know trending
towards you know innovation days
hackathons or in a way or there are some
organizations that dedicate at least
like there are some organizations that
take it to the extreme they have
innovation weeks so they have a full
week of innovation work happening only
that's something as that pod relations
are coming of it so I hope you found
this useful and I you know I've been
I've been doing with the dogs and so I
wanted to basically pause here for a bit
thank you all for taking up you know
taking the opportunity taking the time
to come in and listen in um and tuning
in to understand how agile is fueling
innovation and also you know getting a
few insights hopefully this was you
you were able to take a few insights so
that said I'll pause here and you know
see if there's any questions that we
could take from you and the pro I'd
responses that might be a felt excellent
Krishna and Krishna thank you for being
here today I appreciate your I always
learn new stuff on these webinars even
though I'm in the back listing to them
over and over again and there's always
something new and insightful it amazes
me awesome as far as my own life course
and career that I'm on the paths i'm on
again great finish to ask specific
questions because we do have an expert
here know if you cut the beginning but
he's worked with small companies all the
way to large companies so he has a
pretty wide range of information and
knowledge they'll take the first
question they take myself because it's
one we always get 90 a couple people
vast it will we be be sharing the
presentation to participants at the end
and the answer is yes we do record all
the different sessions if you go to
simply learn calm and go under support
just request and they'll send you a copy
or a link to the copy it does take up to
24 hours because they look at it and
they make sure it actually comes through
ok and nothing's messed up well we get
into questions I'm going to hand over to
our expert Krishna and we have a lot
coming in which is exciting I do have a
poll that I launch so I'll take over the
screen here and then we'll start going
through some of the questions sure and
let me go we have so many questions it's
hard to pick which ones are to jump into
and then like there's an interesting
question this is kind of important
because it deals with a lot of the whole
setup can you link scrum to agile and
short what is because we have scrum you
have agile we have waterfall we have IT
I a given IL thank you there's a lot of
different acronyms we're throwing around
and where's we're throwing in can you
kind of do an overview of how those all
fit together sure
I'll be happy you and thank you for the
question so agile you know if you if you
were to imagine agile look at this as an
umbrella right and scrum is you know one
of the spokes of the umbrella there's
other methods which are also which other
spokes in the agile umbrella you know
like there's XP which is extreme
programming there is lean there is
Kanban there is crystal there's a turn
or DST em that's it the most popular
software development method is scrum
there's about sixty eight percent of the
organizations that say that they're
following ad hell are actually following
scrum or a combination of scrum and XP
you could choose from any of these
methods but given that the success rate
of projects that follow scrum and there
is a desert survey that a company called
version one does every year and they say
you are you following agile and if yes
then what's been the success rate and so
on to put this close to about seventy
percent of the projects that follow
scrum in software development are
successful and that spot bi enhance the
popularity of scrum so a dell you know
like i said is an umbrella of methods
scrum is for is the most popular one for
new software development Kanban is the
most popular one for flow based systems
of production support kind of an
environment so I hope that answers
served the question this ecology no I
that was really good because it's um I
know I get confused because i'm working
with a lot of different areas i myself
am not a scrum master although I work
with a lot of small companies and end up
in that particular role even though I
don't ask for it let's see some of the
questions it's kind of hard to go
through them and loop them all together
sometimes what is the role of the scrum
master in the last slide there was a
question marks as confused lights ago
what is a specific role the scrum master
okay all right fantastic question so the
scrum master I think in a nutshell he
has two very important roles a it is to
be the process coach for the team and B
it is to be the person who's clearing
impediments that the team reports you
know hope you know either daily or what
happened so process coach when I when I
say process coach you know this person
has to basically be the master of the
scrum process in basically trying to
keep up the time boxes this may seem
like a very very simple activity to do
but this is an art and science as well
for instance the daily stand-up people
you know need to ensure that they
respect the time box and they finish the
stand up in 15 minutes similarly they
could be a retrospective sprint review
and stuff like that while the pilot
whenever in the team obviously you know
in all likelihood knows what ceremonies
are to be planned in a sprint it is a
scrum master who has to give the team
the heartbeat the rhythm or the Karen's
to give them the predictability and how
does that help the fiscal master should
basically send out invites for the stand
up for the whole release so everybody
knows that daily scrum happens at
ten-thirty for instance at this place
and at this time so that way everybody
basically works two words that sync up
meeting and everybody feels responsible
and accountable that they need to come
in and give their their updates during
that meeting describe master at the
beginning of the release can also
determine and set and basically set the
team's routine how do you do that set
you know invite for the daily stand-up
are gone the scum must also knows that
the team has a sprint planning meeting
you know on the last day of every sprint
so that could be basically you are sent
out in advance sprint reviews you know
happen you know on the last day of the
sprint as well those invites go out
sprint retrospectives happen you know
after the Sprint review shall happen to
that can world what does this do a it
helps into it you know everybody
understand that the deadlines are
serious they don't move they start
respecting the time box that's one thing
secondly if there are any logistical you
know we have travel related things that
need to be planned out to say the key
individuals like the product product
owner or the architect if they need to
travel to wherever the majority of the
team is then they will plan their visit
to be timed you're in line with the
release planning and such so one should
give the team you're kind of an outline
of how their life will look every two
weeks there's that amount of
predictability and this is something
that the scrum master should be you're
doing and every day in and day out
should be navigating to the other
stakeholders to ensure that he gets to
clear the impediments that the team
report from time to time so a process
coach in again in summary a process
coach and be servant leader who helps to
clear the team's impediments right
servant leadership is the facilitation
that I spoke about of all of the scum
ceremonies so hopefully that answers a
the question that discord asked
excellent in that's some see I'm going
to have to try to skip around between a
couple different areas because we have a
lot of different variation on some of
the questions let's look a little bit at
the certifications we have people who
are probably at the beginning of their
career the beginning of agile who are
asking well which one is more accepted
ASM or CSM or simply learn offers a SF
and ASM which direction is more
is it more accepted in the industry as
far as do you have suggestions as far as
people who are looking for different
certifications and what direction they
should go in on that sure sure certainly
so and this is a question that that
comes up you know every single time we
do a class and at they are we do a
webinar and this is a very interesting
one so now number one the kind of
certification you do will actually be
out which certification should you
choose actually depends on what you want
to get out of it scrum or the CSM
focuses on and I'm very glad somebody
already asked this question about ask
amber to sachet so scrum or the
certified scrum master course is for
organizations that are already following
scrum and have and is a really
relatively small organizations that only
wants to focus on scram right this the
certified scrum master certification
focuses on just the scrum method however
the other you know methods like the
pmi-acp are the you know agile scrum
master courses focus on the agile
umbrella they not just focus on agile
and scrum of course they do they will
also focus on areas like you know devops
which is you know hannah and you're very
very concurrent rate their bobs as as a
your upcoming mainstream you know
function ITIL or itsm how do
organizations work that have all of
these being used in different parts of
the organization in one part of the
organization let's say the support team
is following Kanban and the development
team is following scrum and so on and so
forth if somebody wants to get a good
appreciation of the different kinds of
frameworks and how an amalgamation of
these or you know how they how the
handshake happens between key roles of
scrum
and kanban and lean and end and such
then the comprehensive course is like
the pmi-acp or the agile scrum master by
X in those are far more comprehensive
scrum is you know it just focused on one
method which is you know scrump itself
as a nexus so like I said pick and
choose whatever works best for you if
you're looking for a much more
comprehensive course you can take the AG
you know the agile you know scrum master
the PMI XP if you're just looking at you
know bettering your understanding of
young scrump in a certified scrum master
may be a good goes for you too thick
excellent let me ask you more on a
personal level because this question I
see all the time in these and I see like
50 different variations of it I'm gonna
come yeah we asked hey if you have a
project and you have to hit adhere to
strict delivery date and then you get to
the end and I'll send your detailed
requirements along the way reveal much
greater complexity and the of course
none of us have ever had that problem
working with small businesses where they
wanted out tomorrow and it turns out
that what they're asking for is just
really complicated when you get to the
details could you relay like a personal
experience on that where you had to deal
with that and the communication and team
team building or whatever you'll connect
it to that what happens we render that
wall where they're saying we need this
out and we have this strict guideline
time has to be set how do you work with
that sure ok and this is a you know this
is a very interesting question and I'm
very glad somebody basically touched
upon this um and this is reality today
now here's the thing now you know if you
were to imagine your to access the
x-axis and the y-axis please imagine we
please imagine the certainty of
requirements on the x-axis and the
certainty of technology on the y-axis
right if you do that I think it's it's
easier to do picture this if both your
sudden if your level of change in both
the functionality that you have to build
and technology that you have to work
using if they are not going to change
too much and if you know rock solid both
the requirements and the the technology
then you're on the obviously in the
bottom left quadrant right close to the
X and Y axis in which case you know you
do not need to follow as i write so
because you know you know rock solid you
know things are not going to change the
requirements are you know clearly laid
out you know the technology you know is
not going to change in which case you do
not need to that's it there will still
be an advantage or following a child
right but it's not mandatory the
advantage is that every every two weeks
we get to showcase what it is that we
thought the customer wanted get their
feedback and then make corrections along
the way that's one if you're if both and
if I'll take to the extreme right axis
in the interest of time if you look you
know if you look at a 45 degrees angle
both your technology is is variant is
likely to change and your requirements
are likely to change which means that
you're on the top right corner and
that's the other extreme and that's the
extreme where you absolutely want to
follow a tell because you have no idea
if you are heading in the right
direction so you want to basically
inspector that every few you know
opportunities that you get now um and
and obviously you're either if either
requirements or the other technologies
uncertain it still makes a lot of sense
when it makes most sense and it's
absolutely mandatory for you to your
follow attack now that said if somebody
here complicated the question further by
saying you know we how do you ensure
that you do you know how do you ensure
that you do fixed I'm projects and also
meet the you know all the customers
requirements that way if you're
following a chat so in exile we
basically say that we have X your course
is pretty much the constant so that's a
good thing why because we say we have X
number of developers in the team and the
cost per sprint for these developers is
why you want us to work on a five
sprints we will basically you know
here's your cost or cost per sprint is X
so if you want us to work for the next
ten weeks which is five mins then the
cost is 5x if you want us to work for
the next ten Sprint's then the cost is n
X at the end of every two weeks we will
come back to you dear customer and you
can change the requirements the way you
would like us to change now this is
brought this probably gives the supplier
more flexibility and E and I think it's
in the best interest of the customer as
well to give us this you know to work on
an agile engagement because they will be
sure that they're getting what they want
for the price of they are paying us
right in an agile your kind of an
environment we do not I think it is not
the best thing to basically luck in
scope and schedule right and and if and
if push comes to shove there are still
customers who say that you know you have
to do both of them then obviously you
will do something called release
planning which basically gives us a
fantastic opportunity to look skip
through and basically kind of you know
get an overview of all of the
requirements that we are likely to
undertake over the next release give a
you know get a get the opportunity to
ask questions to the product owner and
only make commitments for the most
viable product and you know the parts
that are most you know most valuable to
the customer so now in a nutshell which
methodology should you follow depends as
L is far more successful there are
trends that I showed you
in software development so agile is
always you know at the mainstream method
I've given you examples of Salesforce
Amazon Google they're all trying google
and are getting great success number one
when your requirements are technology
either of these are likely to change or
both of these are likely to change as L
will give you the advantage and the
opportunities to inspect and adapt your
far more frequently how do you do team
building and there were other questions
related to that I mean obviously given
that as opposed to the conventional
conventional methods agile basically has
a strong emphasis on a physically you
know sitting as many people as possible
you know in close proximity you're they
have linear seeding they sync up every
single day they do you know something
they do follow practices like collective
core ownership and such I think these
are fantastic work related opportunities
for the team to barn but even if you are
separated you know physically if you're
basically you working out of different
geographies there are tools that that I
used very efficiently and given that the
sync up happens almost every day the
teams tend to bond once the team's bond
well and the morale is high they
obviously tend to deliver you know far
you know far better they seem far more
engaged and so there could be other
related questions but we couldn't get to
those parts of the questions but I hope
this answers your question about the
choice of the methodology that needs to
be taken up when something should we
take up and how to work with distributed
beams hmm thank you do you have time i
went ahead and return control to your
screen if you go if you have anything
you want to switch to and we can go a
little bit we are a little bit over but
it's okay to go another five minutes if
that's okay take a few more questions
sure and i want to go ahead and say
you're welcome to Ayman Amon I hope I'm
saying their name correctly then also a
TJ TJ Emerson TJ said thanks for the
affirmation that my team is on the right
path we started our address
transformation in January and it's good
to hear we are on track I was a good to
be back like that coming in we get
people from all walks of life always
amazes me where people are starting a
career and we have people who have like
years of experience or just want to know
a little bit more moving forward just
quite an array of people come here we
have from rajeev agile embraces change
but what if there is a change to be
included which requires expert resources
from the same project who are already
locked in for existing sprint work in
the project can anja ed I'll handle this
effectively does that make sense I'm
hoping that look that question makes
sense for you sure aside the ice at
battery is a question and this is you're
reading it bad if is it so just so that
I get this right I think the situation
is such that the there's a scrum team
let's call this alpha and these guys are
working on a sprint while this team is
you know while everybody is fully
working to their fullest capacity the
customer comes up with you know or the
product owner comes up and says here's
another bunch of requirements and
obviously this team has to a drop what
they're doing even if they drop what
they're doing they are not the expert so
if you will they will need another set
of experts to basically chip in and you
know head how do you manage this
situation right so um so Richard is it
is that your understanding two of the
question I believe so yes all right cuz
i understand it yeah if that is the
situation so there's two rules who
obviously you know play an important
role here number one a this requirement
you know obviously we can only honor any
changes to the requirements once the
sprint end so obviously as you know as
somebody who has to you know push back
on these requirements are basically say
wait till we begin the next print it has
to be the perfect order the product
owner is the one who works closely with
the scrum master right if the if
taking up new work is going to impede
the team's progress then obviously the
scrum master gets engaged so this time
mast and the product owner try and have
this conversation they may will bring
this up you know in one of the grooming
meetings to say hey here's the new set
of requirements that the customer wants
us to work on right the team will
obviously say that a whether a that they
do not have the skills you know to be
able to work on this or they need you
know some additional training or
coaching or what have you now this is
not very uncommon right now the and
obviously not fully in our control right
obviously the customer wants something
that needs to be worked upon us now
here's what we can do the while the
external environment is not in our
control the internal environment is a we
can do one of two things a in the
upcoming sprint we basically add another
scrum team if that is available in the
organization to basically you know work
alongside of the steam who have the
skills that are required to basically
you know work on the new work that's
gonna come a come up either that is an
option or be postponed or basically
schedule this work you know for a later
time if that can wait so that this team
can basically upskill themselves and
acquire the skills required to you know
but to start working on this but I
didn't given that you know somebody
mentioned that you know this requires
expert resources expertise is not
something that this team can you know
acquire over the next you know a week or
two weeks or so so time is what will
determine which where we go if we have
the luxury of time then we basically you
know let this requirement you know you
sit there in the product backlog till
the team acquire sufficient level of
expertise and they take up one story at
a time and then basically once you know
somebody gainsaid expertise they pick it
up if we have the liberty of time if
we don't then we switch to the other
option which is to supplement the scheme
with another scrumpy and you know who
will basically pick this up so that
there isn't an interruption in that
service available third approach could
be a Midway where if we have the
resources available in the organization
who can help and if we only have a you
know a few resources like three or four
resources who can help then seeding the
scrum team with those resources to
upskill these individuals so that
together they can you pick these things
up is is an option however that's it the
third obviously comes with the risk that
when you add new individuals to a
project it will slow down the entire
team because they do not necessarily
have all of the business and the project
context so they will take a while they
will obviously ask a lot of questions
and in in totality may slow down the
team a little bit but in the long run
they'll pick it up so I hope that
answers your question and like i said
the amount of time we have in hand is
what will determine which of these
approaches we will take and i have seen
you know all of these approaches work in
a erp implementations that have followed
agile methodologies at large you know
financial and insurance companies where
they were insurance plans that were to
be rolled up ahead of their competition
so these situations to come up from time
to time and and obviously some
organizations like insurance giants or
for that matter financial services
companies want to basically introduce
some of the cutting edge technology to
figure out how can they do next best
action marketing for the customers by
harvesting social media and all of the
big data so these are these were
requirements which are nish which
weren't there in the beginning of the
project but came in midway so you know
depending on how much like i said
depending on how much time you have in
hat you pick up one of these approaches
either do it yourself at let you know at
a sustainable pace
actually over the next few sprints you
basically supplement this team with
another expert in are basically do the
ceiling approach with Cesar to get just
a few experts embedded into this team so
hopefully that answers the question
excellent I thought it better there was
well well that definitely covered a lot
of ground of course I'm not an expert so
I might be missing something myself like
I said I always learn something new on
these webinars just uh I think we have
time for one maybe two more questions
off of here chammak away then one day a
couple people asking different
variations on is how can we improve the
team performance and scrub scrub scrub
teams how can we move the team
performance whicli do to get our team up
and running sure okay and I think
somebody you know ask this question
exciting there isn't that quick recipe
to do this but I think there are a few
ingredients that I can you know tell you
that go in the recipe I can tell you the
whole recipe in itself because you know
this is a visit both an art and science
and this multiple think that need to be
tried up however that said the things
that motivate it you know are basically
improved productivity are the following
number one does the team understand why
they are doing what they are doing which
is nothing but sharing the vision or
sharing the big picture and so this
requires support from mainly from the
product owner or the product manager now
there's a difference between saying can
you build me a screen which has L you
know a user ID password and a submit
button um and then show me when you're
you know any when you've gotten anywhere
and then I'll give you feedback and we
can work it readily there's a difference
between that and the other approach
which is to say hey we basically trying
to build the next ecommerce app your
mobile application I'd really like you
to you know to understand
that this is a feature which is gonna
basically are we want to basically I'm
back on this project and this is going
to be helping as increase our revenues
you know greatly from six hundred
million dollars today to two billion
dollars tomorrow that's the you have the
opportunity to make that impact this
feature obviously will help and it will
be a starting point will be a gateway to
getting customers who will help us
achieve that business objective that we
have so the part product or the project
objective is to build the login screen
have a few you know features like
chicken check out you know a payment
gateway discounts you know and so on so
what [ __ ] now imagine sharing this big
picture and how individuals will feel so
much a part of the game rather than just
being you know treated like robos to say
hey can you build me a screen which has
user ID password that's you know that
that's not very helpful now a sharing
the vision sharing the big picture is
one thing that the team's get number two
what else motivates teams is obviously
the sense of autonomy and the you know
and the encouragement to get mastery and
sense of autonomy is to say that you
know this is a self-managed
self-empowering a team there are
obviously you know things that managers
people managers need to do to help
create self-organizing teams and once we
say you know to see the self-organizing
teams then these are teams that own the
code together that help each other out
that basically you know we'll bill
basically constantly work on delivering
value will do peer reviews QA becomes as
a developer becomes q8 depending on the
situation and vice versa so the rest the
second ingredient is to build on help
build self-organizing teams right and
and once you build self-organizing teams
you know something almost magical
happens which is that
the teams start to make the team level
decisions on their own they only go to
you know the you know senior management
when they have to make decisions which
have an economy of scale impact which
have a huge financial impact right so
just imagine you know how how great it
would be if the teams can make decisions
like you know a if they worked on two
stories in the previous print those two
stories or one story is completely
accepted the other story has a few bugs
reported in it the product owner
basically is ready in the you know next
sprint he's given another couple of
stories through the team that's the team
even need to you know ask you know the
vice president of engineering whether
they should fix these bugs first or if
that's a priority or should they
basically pick up new features and
functionality and they can they're not
going to release this any time soon so
is it okay to differ those bugs still
like another couple of sprints and they
can fix it later this is a decision that
the team needs to make by themselves
they need to understand that and and
basically you know internalize the fact
that because they worked on the first
couple of stories they obviously must
have been the highest valuable stories
they're better off getting those done
done before they can move up to a story
so that the team needs to do all that
they can in making recommendations and
owning it things are other things like
you know should the team actually invest
time in automating the test cases for
the first couple of stories that they
did is this a is this a question that
they should ask you the director of
engineering or the your VP of
engineering it makes no sense the team
needs to understand the the benefit and
the fact that having a robust automation
framework is just like having a very
solid backbone you cannot have the you
cannot be fearless when you're trying to
check in a new piece of code unless you
have a robust automation framework which
will basically catch and throw errors
right away and tell you with
it's safe or unsafe to basically take up
or merge new code right so so that is
the second ingredient a externally
product owner product manager sharing
the vision and be the team's becoming
self organizing our XP values or extreme
programming values is the third third
ingredient and I'll stop here the third
ingredient most scrum teams that follow
your scram are at a dell should be also
following extreme programming practices
of course the team's morale and pro the
team's productivity can only be higher
if the team's productivity is higher XP
or extreme programming practices have
proven to be extremely successfully
contributing to the quality of software
and so that would be my very strong
recommendations things like their
programming you know test-driven
development these are some practices
which improve productivity quality and
the confidence of the team to release
code so those are a few things that I
would suggest and needless to say if the
team should very very strongly embrace
the basic tenets of agile which is to be
transparent for you know transparent in
showcasing your programs through your
burn down charts or your Kanban boards
always be willing to inspect and always
be willing to make a tag you know
adaptations to your processes from time
to time and be open to learning new ways
so those would be other other recipe
ingredients in the recipe so sharing the
vision building self organizing team
extreme programming practices are three
things that I would very strongly
suggest besides how continue to live the
agile values of you know transparency
inspection and adaptation excellent
excellent thank you thank you Chris nur
sure we
for secondly extended so far so we do
need to go ahead and close this session
again Krishna thank you for being here
today we had a lot of thanks on the on
the chat window so from Reggie was
thinking you and there's a number of
other people I think already closed them
out Oksana slob Aparna thanks a lot nice
webinar thanks for the answer so just
some wonderful feedback I always like to
make sure you hear that since you do
take time out of your day to come join
us and do these webinars sure absolutely
and you know I must say you know i know
i'm i'm very grateful for people to
taking the time or i don't know which
part of the world they're joining us
from but i think you know and this is a
work day so I really appreciate
everybody taking the time out joining
and I really enjoyed answering these
questions so thank you very much for
asking these questions it gives me an
opportunity to think and you know you
know associate my sense of you know or
my desire to be a coach so thank you
very much excellent thank everybody for
being here I look forward to seeing you
in our classrooms that simply learn you
certainly can go to our forums and ask
additional questions we do have open
community forums that simply learn com
it's / community but you can go to the
main page and you'll see a community if
you have any additional questions you
can certainly ask them there and there's
also a great place if you have questions
on the certification programs to Krishna
I'm going to go ahead and close the
session if you want to say one last
goodbye before we shut down all right
sure goodbye um and gracias thank you
very much actually I love that gracias
everybody take care of a wonderful day
or evening
you